allez Florent direction à présent
Château-Renault où l'un des immeubles
emblématiques de la ville va disparaître
oui loin des grands ensemble du Sanitas
à Tours la tour de la gare tranche dans
le paysage urbain de la petite ville de
l'ouest tout enjaux devenu vétust à
l'aube de ses 50 ans l'immeuble est
depuis quelques jours grignoter par les
engins de chantier sous le regard ému
des habitants royaux Romeo Marmin
alerte météo à Château-Renault il pleut
des pierres
les yeux des habitants sont tournés vers
le ciel certains assistent un brin
nostalgique à la destruction de leur
ancienne immeuble
j'ai habité là pendant 15 ans j'étais au
11e étage appartement 70 et j'étais la
dernière partie j'y suis resté un mois
toute seule dans la tour j'étais bien
là-haut j'avais une belle vue et puis
là-bas en marloé en face je suis bien
aussi
les travaux pour démolir la grande tour
de 11 étages ont débuté mercredi 6
septembre
et si certains regrettent le bâtiment
presque quinquagénaire ce n'est pas le
cas de tous les habitants
je pense que cette tour a laissé un peu
périmée maintenant il faut il faut que
ce soit démoli quoi aller plus aux
normes comme il y avait de l'amiante et
il se couchaient et il était quand même
mon bascule donc on soit doté qu'un jour
l'autre il allait quand même des détruit
détruire les vestiges du passé pour
mieux construire le futur c'est la
direction qui a décidé de prendre la
mairie de Château-Renault
avec la ville de Château-Renault un
projet de réhabilitation du quartier et
tout ça ça va se faire dans la durée et
en partenariat aussi avec la population
les travaux devraient s'étendre sur un
mois après plusieurs années de retard
des centaines d'hirondelles c'était
installé sur ce nichoir géant
depuis ses habitants à plume ont eux
aussi été relogées